we're asked to sort the following units
of measurement into two categories US
customary units and metric units so
these are just two different systems and
you'll get more and more familiar with
them then indicate whether each unit
measures length weight mass or volume so
let's do the first let's see which of
these are US customary units versus
metric units so the leader is a metric
unit leader is a metric unit you would
use it in the metric system a gallon is
a US customary unit we've been dealing
with that when you if you fill your
gasoline in Europe you're going to be
filling it in terms of leaders in the
u.s. you're going to be filling it in
terms of gallons now we're going to talk
about whether their units of volume and
whatnot in a little bit decigram that is
metric system that is metric system
metric system in general whenever you
see these prefixes deci centi kilo
you're dealing with the metric system no
one ever talks about a kilo pound I
guess you could but no one really talks
about it same thing millimeter this is
metric system the gram is metric system
meters metric system the foot is the
u.s. cuss us customary unit we'll talk
about whether it's distance or any of
that a little bit
kilogram once again it is metric units
it is metric blufor metric in case you
haven't gotten what I'm doing here blue
for metric red for US customary unit so
I guess magenta sent a liter that is
metric centimeter meters our metric and
notice we have the prefix in both cases
centi means one hundredths cup that is
US customary units you have to do that
in the magenta cup US customary units
meter that is the metric system meter is
a metric system pound u.s. customary
units is getting a little tedious inch
same thing that's what we use in the US
ounce we use that in the US and then the
yard we also use that in the US now
we've divided them up all the magenta
ones are used in the US all of the blue
ones are used really in the rest of the
world and actually some places
the US as well I think a lot of the
world is frustrated that the US doesn't
that we're not all converted to this
because the metric system is actually a
little bit more logical it's easy to
just figure out what it's saying and
we'll deal with that in more detail in
the future now the next thing we need to
figure out is whether something is mu
measure of length weight / mass and
they're not exactly the same thing mass
is how much of a substance you have
weight is how much grab the force with
which gravity is pulling on that mass
and it could change depending on what
planet you're on but in you know on
earth they they tend to be used
interchangeably so we'll use it roughly
interchangeably here and then you have
volume or how much space something takes
up so this is distance this is you know
moving in one dimension this is how mass
is how much stuff there is weight is how
much the force that that stuff is pulled
on I'm gonna plant it by gravity or I
guess a star anywhere and volume is how
much space does that stuff take up now
let's think about it liter liter is
volume this right here is volume how
much space do you take up gallon is also
volume that's in the in the US and in
Europe or in the metric system it would
be liter decigram gram gram is a unit of
mass is a unit of mass so decigram just
means one tenth of a gram millimeter
meter is a unit meter right here that is
a unit of distance or of length of
length milli meter milli means one
thousandth of a meter foot that is also
a unit of length kilogram
that just means 1,000 grams kilo means a
thousand gram we already said is a unit
of mass centiliter that means one
hundredth of a liter liter we already
figured out is a unit of volume
centimeter we already figured out meter
is a unit of length centimeter means one
hundredth of a meter so this is a unit
of length a unit of length cup we've
seen multiple times already it is a unit
of volume how much space does something
take up
meter that is length seen it multiple
times already pound that is actually a
unit of weight that is a unit of weight
an inch is a unit of length we're all
familiar with it and ounce is when this
you have to be careful here if someone
just says an ounce that is 1/16 of a
pound it is a unit of weight if it was
written fluid ounce then we'd be talking
about 1/16 of a pint and then it would
be a unit of volume but this is just on
sits a unit of weight 1/16 of a pound
and then finally a yard is a unit of
length and we are done